[Musique]
ce que j'aime chez Nicole ouais c'est une
grande danseuse
contagieuse c'est une mère qui joue
vraiment joue elle donne une grande présence
[Musique]
elle est compétitive elle sait quand me pousser
et quand me laisser longtemps
[Musique]
comme toujours devrait parler  d'accord je ne sais pas
comment commencer ce que j'aime chez Charlie
il adore être papa c'est presque
ennuyeux à quel point il aime ça il pleure
facilement dans les films
j'ai pleuré quatre fois moi aussi il est très
compétitif c'est quoi qui possède Baltic
Avenue il est très clair  à propos de ce qu'il
veut
il est un grand habilleur n'a jamais l'air
embarrassant ce qui est difficile pour l'homme il
prend toutes mes humeurs régulièrement il
ne me fait pas me sentir mal à leur sujet il est
rarement vaincu ce que j'ai
toujours l'impression de faire
[Musique]
comme toujours  parle bien je ne sais pas
comment commencer avec toi
[Musique]
toi